we've got an update to a story we told
you about last week a twelve-year-old
girl in Northern Virginia admitted she
lied about three white classmates
cutting off her dreadlocks the girl
accused the sixth-grade boys at a
private Christian school of calling her
hair ugly and nappy holding her down and
cutting it with scissors during recess
she acknowledged the allegations were
false after a police investigation the
girl's family issued a statement reading
quote to those young boys and their
parents we sincerely apologize for the
pain and anxiety these allegations have
caused we understand there will be
consequences and we're prepared to take
the responsibility for them the head of
the school said while we are relieved to
hear the truth and bring the events of
the past few days to a close we also
feel tremendous pain for the victims and
the hurt on both sides of this conflict
yeah it's this story was so tough when I
heard about it yesterday made me sad
angry and disappointed I thought about
the three little boys who had been
falsely accused why she would make this
up there has to be more to this story
about what she was thinking I'd like to
know that at the end of the day it's a
terrible thing - terrible accusation
look at least they figured it out
quickly that was an apology from the
family and the school exactly and what
we do is dependent on trust that's why
you always say says you know you have
initial reports exact thing we always
say says do we know if she'll get to
stay in the school do we know we don't
at all we know that our affiliate
whoosah reported that she actually cut
her own hair so as you say go there may
be more to the story that we haven't
learned yet